还记得诺基亚吗
如今 它早就不是卖手机的了
而是悄悄地
变身成了一家AI基建的隐形巨头
最近诺基亚股价一路狂飙
创下了十多年的新高
机构扎堆看好
甚至还将它列入了
AI基础设施领域的首选标的
那么在这背后到底发生了什么呢
诺基亚现在的业务
主要是两大板块
一块是网络基础设施
另一块是移动基础设施
其中 光通信业务
无疑是诺基亚眼下
最亮眼的增长爆发点
也是短期逆袭的核心抓手
2013年
收购了阿尔卡特朗讯
获得了IP路由
与光传输融合的核心技术
以及贝尔实验室的研发体系
后来 它又瞄准了
数据中心互联（DCI）的
高速光传输赛道的缺口
补齐光芯片
高速光模块的技术短板
形成了从 “芯片、模块、系统” 的
光通信全产业链布局
而在AI算力需求
全面爆发的当下
全球各大云厂商、数据中心都
急需高速稳定的光网络传输支撑
而诺基亚
恰好就卡位在了这条黄金赛道
诺基亚的一季度财报显示
光网络收入大涨20%
AI与云客户收入增长49%
单季贡献新增订单10亿欧元
公司此次还透露
已经在与AI和云厂商深度合作
定制的网络系统
并有望带来持续的重复采购
诺基亚还有一个
更具有想象力的长期故事
那就是AI+RAN
RAN 其实就是
我们手机日常接入网络的
基站无线网络
在过去 RAN的流量分配
频谱调度 都是预先设定好的
但是引入了AI之后
每一个基站都可以变成
一个具备计算和
智能调度能力的节点
从“传输网络”
升级成“分布式算力网络”
去支撑自动驾驶、机器人
AR/VR这些
对低延迟要求极高的应用
而这也是去年10月
英伟达拿出十亿美元
投资诺基亚的底层逻辑
要做AI-RAN
光有芯片和算法不够
必须先有建基站的资格
诺基亚的产品遍布全球所有基站
其Airscale平台
更是被应用于
全球数百万个基站中
如果我们的计算机不在基站内
那就毫无用处
英伟达的入局之后
双方的分工也很清晰
英伟达出GPU算力平台
诺基亚出基站硬件
和全球运营商渠道
两家合体打造
AI原生的下一代网络
AI+RAN
大规模商业部署
预计要到2028年前后才会到来
但是一旦这条路跑通
诺基亚的定位就完全不一样了
它将成为
全球分布式边缘计算基础设施
最核心的供应商之一
实际上
最近“卷土重来”的
老牌手机巨头
不止诺基亚一家
比如 曾经风靡一时的黑莓
也是当前自动驾驶和机器人领域
重要的AI基础平台
摩托罗拉
如今它是军警、矿山
应急等专网通信领域的全球龙头
也在折叠屏等小众市场站稳脚跟
爱立信深耕6G
企业私有5G和网络AI化
时代从来不会淘汰
有核心技术的公司
只有固守老旧路径的思维